with comic-con at home happening
this was the one i was most excited for
which wasn't part of comic-con
justice khan zack snyder uh spoke for
about an
hour on uh snyder cuts some things to
expect he unveiled like
20 seconds of something didn't watch it
but i listened to the whole thing i
basically had it on my iphone
while i was doing some other stuff and i
was listening to the interview so here's
what we're gonna do i wanted to talk
about
some of the things that he brought up
riff on that a little bit but also
i want to actually see this footage
because i believe this clip
was released online already especially
for some things that he talked about how
they released this clip without his
permission but this one is
black suit superman so let's check this
out and then uh i want to talk about
some of the other things that he
mentioned
this is how i roll it's like with the
vero clip it was like all right
i'm gonna listen to it but once there's
any footage or something unveiling
look away yeah let's see
how we do a lot of this yeah
see how you see that kind it's just of
charcoal
[Laughter]
interesting interesting clip i remember
this clip
uh from a while ago i mean i'll show you
some footage right now that they did
release it online
um i don't remember exactly when it's a
little bit longer than that i don't know
what the deal is i don't know if they
when they really if they shot it with
black suit superman and then when they
released this clip they were like no we
got to add it to the color or did they
reshoot the scene because
like playing it back it looks shot by
shot the same exact thing right yeah
except the color
beyond the black suit it's like the
entire color correction is more in tune
with what whedon put together himself
and like a lot of the palette around him
is a different type of shade but the
shading and all the
all the cinematography obviously is all
digitally touched up in the one that was
released online but what he released
like what what he specifically said
was that he wanted to show this little
tidbit even though this clip is online
with
the you know red and blue suit this was
more about showing like no this is going
to be the realizing
of an idea superman really arcing into
the superman
that we know and even though this isn't
the highest quality maybe someone will
release a higher quality one online
later this does look better
oh yeah like everything every bit of the
cinematography and the visual language
of it does look a lot more crisp
i wonder to how this might change when
it actually finds
its way into the finished cut because
you know i mean it was released as a
deleted scene in the first place so it
may not
even then have been full on color
corrected or whatever but
i have to imagine you can you can do a
lot a lot a lot with color corrections
so i wouldn't be
surprised if they just went in and
tweaked the palette instead of getting a
whole new shot or something like that
yeah i mean there's some fun things like
seeing
uh or hearing at least what the chat was
talking about really asking about green
lantern and the way he like
dodged the question made it seem like
there's gonna be more of a green lantern
presence perhaps you know you get a hint
of it in the one that we didn't did the
way he was dodging it was like yep it's
a
it's a thing like the way he was
answering it was so funny
that's him going all right some of that
20 to 30 million
is going to go into adding some green
land
just to get some more exclusive stuff he
was doing the live stream to see like
what is everyone really doing
all right okay okay cool cool cool add
some stuff so
i mean there were some fun questions
that were asked about how to he he knows
how to like dodge
certain answers because they were asking
him specifically about was it his idea
to like have whedon step in and he
didn't say it was his idea to have joss
whedon take over but he did own up and
saying that it was him and deborah's
idea to step away
from the movie that they do take
ownership over that part they did ask
him about if they would you if he would
use any of
whedon's footage and he went on this
whole hilarious rant you can watch the
whole thing online he won this hilarious
rant
about like how he would rather burn this
film than use
any of that you know now the thing is he
didn't take any specific
jabs at the version we didn't did
necessarily there were some
jabs that were taken at the fact of you
know making
hilarious moments out of the
resurrection of superman
and how that just doesn't make sense to
him yeah um
but other than that he's steered clear
of starting any
direct feud with joss whedon yeah over
this
no beef brewing at the moment although
that could also be a clap at
warner's too because you know they were
probably pretty handy in
tinkering with the film themselves i
just watched justice league dark
apocalypse uh yesterday you know it's
gotten me really in the mood to
see some of darkseid now brought to life
like i've already been looking forward
to it but the other thing that really
intrigued me and during this discussion
is
about how steppenwolf is he's going back
to his original design
he wants darkseid to accept him and take
him back it's supposed to be a fluid
storyline of darkseid and steppenwolf
both being infused
into here so as much as we're all
excited to see darkseid
i'm actually really excited to see a
properly
done originally executed version of
steppenwolf himself
there are certain things that get
brought up from like chris randolph's
interview to things he's said in the
past to even hear
oh yeah i haven't even really been
considering that fact a proper take on
steppenwolf he might be a real character
yeah he wasn't a real character the
design on him and the visual effects
were
were
poorly done because as much as i'm
someone who says like i really had a lot
of fun with the version that was
released
i will completely agree with everyone
that the steppenwolf character and
design
everything was not good right yeah uh it
could have been better
definitely wasn't that element now i'm
like ooh a properly done
steppenwolf not just dark side but
steppenwolf
him honing in on that and the other fun
thing that was brought up was this might
not even be called zack snyder's justice
league
that would be an interesting uh change
up if he gave it like a whole new title
or something like that
yeah he's saying that a lot of this is
going to be
uh properly touched on and more unveiled
at dc fandom
like he had permission to use this clip
for justice khan but
at dc fandom we'll we will be getting an
actual teaser
according to him an actual teaser he
said more footage and then clarified it
with an actual teaser yeah and also
there's this whole thing about a shirt
oh the the borg life shirt yeah where
you can get like an associate producer
cred on it which i want to get now
oh you should yeah you've been
championing championing this
i do i do want the i want the shirt yeah
yeah
hey man i heard some of the ray fisher
panel and i started kind of getting
jealous for one
ray fisher was uh bringing it up first
beforehand and the other
intriguing part which i'm hoping hbo max
does decide to do
i remember that they released some game
of thrones episodes
one of the season premieres or season
finales i can't remember which one it
was they put it in imax
assuming by the time the snyder cut does
come out that
some theaters will be reopened yeah yeah
yeah and as
and i love imax he said that he
originally shot this
to be an imax like bvs i did see that in
imax
he likes working with imax cameras and
he was saying that like the footage that
was unveiled with wonder woman learning
about darkseid and such
the reason that's in that ratio format
is because you had to shoot it in that
way for
imax yeah you have a square frame
instead of a rectangle yeah so he was
saying that he didn't like release it
in that way you know for like instagram
footage or something
you you have to shoot in a very specific
format so they've been having to
reformat it for hbo max right but now
i'm like
wait guys this is a huge hit and he said
a dc fandom
they will unveil if this is gonna be a
movie or a series but either way i'm
like
i mean sure release on hbo max first but
either you should have a special event
down there rotary put this in imax
especially since it was shot originally
for
imax oh yeah i feel like if theaters are
a thing when this drops it would be kind
of foolish not to do some kind of
theatrical engagement because of
again how rabid the fan base is and how
supportive
yeah i mean there are times when it is
said that the geek fan base doesn't
always
show up but in this case i i definitely
definitely think they will
i mean i've watched movies that i don't
really care about but i've
gone back and rewatched them just
because they're in imax
because i love when films are shot for
imax i just love the visual
experience of it even if like the movie
itself i'm not a fan of
but i'll go revisit it in imax just
because it's an imax and i would
definitely do that for this
it's a whole other immersion yeah
especially for a fantasy world like this
and with the kind of grit zack snyder
likes to put in his movies i feel like
an imax experience would be pretty
dazzling and the funny thing too
because a lot of some of the other cast
has seen the the snyder cut or whatever
cut he currently
had before all this was getting funded
by hbo max and at t
people like jason momoa ray fisher uh as
cyborg he's
said many times that he's like the heart
of this story ray fisher himself hasn't
actually seen this movie
he hasn't seen it zack snyder refuses to
let him see it until it's close to being
complete
and then they're going to release a
reaction yeah
see him checking out the movie that'd be
awesome honestly it would be because too
it would be the perfect place for all
the people to join and like watch it
with him i would be down
as far as this goes i mean it was a
really he he's a fascinating person to
listen to on an interview i was hoping
we'd get like a teaser trailer here or
some more footage or whatever
the information alone i thought was very
interesting and if anything
now i'm just super excited for dc fandom
to see what's unveiled there
dark side steppenwolf some fun wheat and
stuff you can watch the whole interview
from justicecon i think it's really well
worth your time i just want to touch on
some highlights
yeah and and tune in to that joss whedon
zoom call at comic-con
yeah complete the trilogy
but guys snyder cut did you listen to
the interview
what excited you most from the
information revealed let us know below
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell last but not least
kent mcnoy our old australian friend
been a long time since we've been really
catching up talking with him in patreon
messages recently it's funny because in
the times of cove but a lot of people
in whatever industry they're working
have been dealing with a lot of harsh
harsh financial situations fortunately
for him he's in the
horticulture industry doing a lot with
plants and such
hashtag plant life and because a lot of
people are quarantined and such
a lot of people are buying more plants
so he's actually been way more busy here
during this time
cleaning up so kent last time we talked
with you
you battled a medical condition and you
overcame it
and now with this terrible medical thing
going around
you're able to profit man
back this is your revenge you're like
wall street and big
pharma you're just getting all those
dollars in from the covis
keep it up kent happy to know you buddy
glad you're still around our patreon
page after so long
it was really nice to see your name pop
back up yeah love you man
hope we can talk to each other again
soon see